這個系列叫做
歌有仇必報
第一堂課
我們請小哥先教我們做K棒
黑K棒不一定下跌
收盤價
比昨天的收盤價來得高
紅K取決看誰積極
通常是主力比較積極
對 主力再買比較會是紅K
對
坊間有一個叫你
48種K棒的用法
小哥幫你減掉45種K棒
通常我們看到跳空跳空
根本不敢追
各位不用怕追高
認得K棒這根最好用
掛掌聽板賣出 跌聽板買進
這是很糟糕的
萬劍傳心
這根是讓你勇敢的追的
好
第一根後面掌上來
最高點掌了175%
已經木了好不好 明部了
小哥我終於等到你了
太好了…
我終於看到官之靈了
東森官之靈
因為我們每次打給你
就說你在日本
然後下次打給你 你又在日本
在打給你 還在日本
因為我太喜歡去日本
對 聽說你 日本不很吃的
對 然後風景還有一些像這娃娃
都去日本抓了
去日本抓娃娃
對 去日本抓娃娃
特別去日本抓娃娃
你演進去 現在行程裡面
大概有每天晚上八點之後
大概就是抓娃娃時間
那你喜歡夾娃娃
是不是夾娃娃跟你做投資
有什麼雷頭 對
因為我覺得這個夾娃
有點像以小伯大
以小伯大
像這個100塊可以夾一隻
100塊日幣
100塊日幣夾到這一隻
這個沒有 這個大概夾500塊
500塊這一隻也很划算
對啊 500塊日幣大概是140塊而已
對啊
就可以夾到那麼大娃娃
這個你在日本的那個
店裡面買大概都要三四千塊
都要三四千塊日幣啦
但是其實我強烈懷疑
你去日本不是為了夾娃娃
你是為了躲我
躲...
因為我一直約你一直約你
你都不肯來
但是你現在終於敢來了
因為我看你們節目實在太優秀
我每次都想說
哇 來參加你們節目
不曉得要準備多久
其實來我們節目的問題不是優秀
是一來就要做十幾
要做十幾
小哥你今天有承諾囉 十幾喔
十幾實在滿恐怖的
怕十幾這倒沒有什麼好講
而且不但十幾
你還要講一些在以前
其他地方你從來沒講過的東西
好 我們今天有講一些
其他地方沒有講過的
今天就有對不對
今天就有
好 今天就有
所以我們今天呢
非常非常的開心
趙華請到誰呢
全正小哥喔
那小哥要帶來的
一開始不是全正
驚訝了吧
小哥要講什麼
小哥要幫我們講一系列的籌碼喔
所以這個系列叫做
歌有籌必報
好不好 歌有籌必報
有籌碼就會報給你喔
那我們今天非常開心
小哥來到現場喔
我們會進行一系列的籌碼課程
而且今天小哥第一堂課
你們會很吃驚
小哥從來沒有講過的K-Bong怎麼看
K-Bong怎麼看喔
那這邊我要再幫小哥介紹一下
全身小哥已經很紅了
因為素以公布你的交易對帳單出名
對 以前蠻常公布的
對 所以通話
我覺得你去學主菜
人家會擺個一盤菜給你看
對 食材要買出來
對啊 你去學理材
總要看看對方的對帳單是怎麼樣
那我不是說一定要賺錢或賠錢
至少要做啦
即便他大賠也是很好啊
我以前不認識你的時候
光是網路上看到你
一直公佈你的交易紀錄啊
我覺得你很驕傲耶
驕傲
對 我想說這個人
怎麼會有人可以這麼
自信暴捧這樣子
可是話認識你覺得不會啊
就是你的日常
賺錢就是日常而已
賺錢就是賺
有時候也會賠錢啦
沒有每次都賺錢啦
做短線交易就是這樣
好 所以大家可能還不曉得
其實小哥以前是理化老師
對
而且念到國立師範大學的一個研究所
國立台灣師範大學
對 本來要出來教理化的
結果現在變成立猜
我大概教了十幾年的理化
我覺得我好佩服你
因為我國中唯一一科有補習的
就是理化 太難了
理化很有意思啦
這邊我要快速念過
小哥的論文是什麼
福尼科學寫作之資訊融入教學隊學生
學習光學單元成效研究
不是不是每一個字都看得懂
聽起來越來越懂對不對
可是拼在一起我一個字都看不懂了
這跟科學教有關
其實裡面的重點是說
我們課文要好好讀啊
就是要課文好好讀
對 課文好好讀
因為以前
小哥的話好好聽
以前我讀書的時候
都直接讀參考書都不讀課文
其實後來發現課文很重要
對 其實小哥
其實你理化教得好
理財應該也會教得好
而且其實理化論文那麼長
理財就是我教你好不好
十萬翻成千萬
很容易懂耶
我喜歡你教這個
好 所以今天小哥的第一堂課
大家千萬記住小哥
真的從來沒有講過
小哥要教我們是籌碼
可是籌碼的入門磚
大家可能沒想過
竟然是什麼
竟然是K棒
其實趙華以前
因為趙華比較習慣做基本面
所以K棒我也是比較不懂
我也是為了小哥來
我就惡補了一會
所以待會小哥一邊幫大家上課
其實一邊也是幫趙華上課
那所以小哥會用教趙華的方法
從前慢慢入身
所以你的第一堂課
我們請小哥先教我們做K棒
小哥說實話我看了K棒
我做股票也是有一定的資歷
很多人猜我幾歲
可是我K棒我一直到你來
我才稍微有搞懂
不是搞得很懂
那我們來講一下
這個K棒的基礎知識
好
先來看一下
這K棒它有分陽線跟陰線
陽線就是紅K對不對
對 陽線就是黑K
陰線就黑K
那陽線跟陰線差在哪邊
陽線它是收盤價比開盤價來的高
收盤比開盤高
那又可能是開低走高
開很低走平也可以
所以看的就是開心就是紅的
那陰線是開高走低
開高走低就不妙了
其實我們做短線交易
有時候我們也蠻喜歡陰線的
為什麼
因為我們做當沖的話
有時候是先賣再買
所以你假如拆對陰線的話
有時候這個報酬是很多的
所以兩條線都非常有用
對 所以做短線線
都每天都在猜
今天是陽線還是陰線
像我的話就搞不懂
我就會覺得當然是紅的好看
也沒有 像我們做空的
還蠻喜歡看到陰線的
所以這邊大家就
如果它是陽線的話
其實這一根代表它的收盤
這邊是開盤
那反過來 剛剛講了黑K的話
開盤在這邊 收盤在這邊
那可他還會有兩根
像蠟燭這樣子的線跑出來
那這上面就要上陰線
那上影線是最高價跟這個實體K棒的中間的這個線
那這線呢 腳很長的話代表今天的賣壓很大
所以怎麼留下長長的上影線
就是感覺上比較不好
上面有人在盜貨
那下影線代表底下支撐很強
那下影線是最低價跟實體K棒的中間這條線
小哥就直接把線是什麼樣組成的
先列給大家看
如果大家對K棒不太熟先看這一張
但是我們一般其實會看薑波圖
對 薑波圖到底怎樣顯示在K棒上面
就是每天有一個薑波圖我會看
開盤架多少 收盤架多少
可要怎麼樣變成一個K棒
那我們來看一下這個
薑波圖像這裡開盤架在這邊
然後往上走之後殺下來再往上走
到最高點之後再殺下來收盤在這邊
所以這個江坡土就可以化成這個K棒
所以開盤在這邊
對應過來是這邊
然後因為中間有殺下去
他就留了一個下影線
然後收盤在這邊 所以在這裡
那盤中有高架就會留上一個上影線
最高架跟收盤架是中間
上影線
所以以前我看的話會以為說
紅K就是長啊
黑K棒不一定下跌
我們來看一下這個
這個黑K棒在當天它是收長的
因為這個實體的K棒的收盤價
比昨天的收盤價來得高
紅K的收盤價在上面
黑K的收盤價在下面
所以即使它是綠的黑K
但是它這個其實比前一天高
它是長的
造法很聰明
沒有 馬上小哥講得很清楚
馬上就知道了
那像這個黑K棒在這邊
你就可以看到它是下跌的
它是下跌的 因為收平價跌
從這邊看出來
我現在才懂欸
我以前看到黑K想疊啦疊啦
紅K長啦長啦
沒有 他只是讓你知道說
今天是開高走跌還開低走高而已
對
好 來看紅K不一定上漲
對 來看這邊
收盤價在這裡
這收盤價在這邊
對
昨天的收盤價在哪邊
在這邊
在這邊 對 答對了
所以這一這個圖呢
他今天是下跌的
紅K但下跌
對 紅K下跌
不過我講盤中看到
你今天收盤看到這個K棒
我也不會覺得太難過啦
是
講我做多的話 因為至少他紅K
我們再來看這個
這個昨天收盤價在哪邊
昨天收盤價在這邊
對 昨天收盤價在這邊
那這個呢
今天收盤價在哪邊 上漲了
在這邊 今天是開的比較低
上漲了
這個是上漲的 這是下跌的
所以同樣是紅K
紅紅K這個是跌 這個是漲
小哥 經過你的教育
我現在雖然看得懂
可是其實我還是不太懂
就是到底為什麼我們要發明K棒
就K棒一定有它的意義對不對
然後再來就是你剛才已經講了嘛
紅K就是你收盤價開盤價一定是高
對不對 所以那代表有主力在做
才會有紅K
好 那我先問你一下
假如這世界上只剩下我們兩個人
你有錢我有股票 對
那今天紅K代表誰動作了
如果世界上只剩我們兩個人
為什麼我們要來做股票這種事情
我可以做點別的
好 還是認真回答
這不是你開節目嗎
對你認真回答
如果你有股票我有錢
那當然是我如果比較想要你手上的股票
股票就會漲上去
沒錯
紅K取決看誰積極
那這積極的不一定是主力
也不一定是散戶
不過通常是主力比較積極
對 因為散戶比較不會去搶股票
散戶比較消極
就每天掛著
有到他價格就買
沒到他價格就算了
所以這邊還真的是
主力在買比較會是紅K
你假如常常看到紅K的話
那代表是主力在買
但是又有例外
又有例外
我們曾經看過一路紅K
對
但主力在盜貨
蛤
為什麼呢
這例外是什麼回事
散戶的覺醒
不是散戶覺醒
是散戶被誘導
被誘導
誰誘導
被某個社團誘導
對 房間很多這種理財社團
都跟你講說
我們要買這一檔
一張不賣
這鼓吹閃霧去買這一檔
那結果主力在到貨
都是閃霧買的
所以有時候會有些例外
我們看到紅K可能大部分的主力
可是如果有像小哥講的
神秘的社團勢力加入的時候
可能閃霧也會把它買上去
也會買上去
那這種後面的下場就不太好
那你等一下會教我們
怎麼抓這種神秘社團嗎
我當然會講神秘社團的案例
好 那剛才我已經被小哥教育過了
我們現在來考網友
網友到底搞不搞得懂
黑K跟紅K怎麼看
好 我們來看第一個
小哥的水糖糕 來啦
登登登登
這邊有一個江坡圖
對 猜一下
網友猜一下 不是猜一下
網友把剛剛學到的
先來應用一下
好 開盤的點
ABCD哪一個K棒
開盤點在這邊
中間有稍微下殺了
又拉起來 收高
我覺得講得很清楚了吧
來
登登登登
網友可以在那個好不好
我們的直播下面留言
影片下面留言
搞不好小哥就會把今天的
Dreamong送給你
好 我來回答好了
因為我剛剛才學嘛
因為他是開低走高
但中間下沙那應該是這一根
答對了
登登
大王那隻 王那隻
好 沒有問題
今天帶都可以送
好 這個我答對了
好 再考一張 再考一張
對 一張可能是懵到
你管是老師
我現在有點壓力
李化老師在考試
我們會鼓勵學生 會送學生獎品
好 送學生獎品
這個是開高
開高
然後一路走低
但是收的時候就稍微拉上來
所以基本上
它應該是留下下影線的黑K
好 答對
這就是留下影線的黑K
光榮啊
開清
K棒滿簡單的
大概就這樣子
其實我們錄影前有聊過
就是坊間有一個教你
48種K棒的用法
小哥說不用看
你浪費了48分鐘
因為只有3種K棒好不好
只有三種K棒你在這堂課需要學
小哥會幫你減掉45種K棒
我們講那個最實用的單根K棒
就三種
K棒它有組合式的
對啊
有組合式
組合式的它是可以
對 那個可以應用
那單根K棒最有用的
其實有三根而已
只有三根
單根的
單根最有用的
好
那第一個叫做光頭大紅棒
是
它是一個發射訊號
對
那這根呢我們建議至少要5%以上
你說5%以上是指什麼
就是說最低點跟最高點
至少5%以上才算
光頭大碗
現在的話就半根漲停板
因為像漲幅是10%
因為有個光頭才1%
那沒什麼用 不夠光
對不夠光 這個光頭要5%
對不夠長 對 這個要5%
第二個叫跳空一致線
那這是紅K喔
這是紅的 這是漲停板
這個的話在很多強勢股
跳空跳空跳空跳空
我們就看到一階一階上去
我們今天教各位怎麼買到重線
我好害怕
通常我們看到跳空跳空
根本不敢追
小哥你現在要教我們追這個
首長庭的股票
你各位不用怕追高
我在這市場上看過太多追高的人
到現在還活著
看過太多低檔攤平的人都掛了
這反市場的思考
趕追高的都活著
喜歡攤貼的都死掉了
所以我們要跟小哥看齊
小哥還活著
就要趕最高
第三個呢高檔掉手線
掉手線
這在轉折很好用
不管是高檔低檔
轉折都很好用
轉折就看這根線
那我們就
太棒了
48根只要看這三根
看這三根
因為呢
很多K棒呢
他會跟你寫說
這根出現之後會怎樣
例如說十字線
對
實質驗出現之後會轉折
那經過統計研究發現之後不顯著
不顯著
不顯著就是它不一定轉折
有可能會在盤整
所以呢這個線就算了
一般人很喜歡看這實質線
好 實質線就算囉
小哥說實質線不用看囉
因為統計上面沒有什麼特別意義
好
不顯著
反正今天小哥就講了三根K棒
基本上一級K棒就把他講完
就KO了
單根的啦
單根的 組合式的其實可以講很多
我們後面還會再講組合式的
現在來講這個光頭大紅包好不好
光頭大紅包
來看一下
去年11月28號的系統店
5309系統店
這是他第一根漲停
對 這個可是這種鎖漲停
對啊 看了就會怕怕的
好像我在追高啊
我們這樣講喔
第一根漲停你不用太擔心
第一根漲停不用太擔心
因為第一根漲停你去追
風險其實很低啊
真的
因為他盤整了很久
然後第一根上來
你去追
假設你停損是在這邊
也才10%而已
所以剛剛有一個keyword
他盤整很久的第一根漲停
所以我們都建議
第一根你要追
那第89根第10根就不要追了
有到第89根我也
眠目了好不好 眠目了
大家都會怕
那這根漲停呢
我們看這邊
他這邊其實開關關的
對
開關關的在第一根也不用怕
也不用怕
因為第一根常常這樣
因為太多閃負
在這檔股票怎麼樣
套很久 等很久
還是在一個盤子的時期我們來看一下
好 這裡 你看喔
這段時間啊
散戶呢 這個買了
賺賺賠賠賠的
忍受了很久的煎熬
忍受很久的煎熬 對
然後呢 有的散戶
每天會打電話掛 漲停板賣出
每天掛 就想解套就對了
每天掛 這個很多散戶的動作這樣
你千萬不要做這種動作
很多人很喜歡掛漲停板賣出
跌停板買進
不對嗎
這是很糟糕的
被說中了
你掛漲停板賣出
你很有可能會賣在旗張點
可是我都漲停板我不賣
跌停板我還不買
你掛跌停板賣進
你很有可能買在旗跌點
所以做股票不要這樣子
萬箭穿心
你看要怎麼樣
那要怎麼樣 你應該勇敢的追
這根是讓你勇敢的追的
我們可以看到
重點是盤子很久很久
盤子很久都沒什麼量
那通常大紅K都會半水的大成交量
這個大紅K讓這些人都解套
讓這些人都解套
可是這一根很多散戶
在這邊持有股票的會賣在這裡
解套就賣
對 很可惜
很可惜
為什麼很可惜
為什麼後續發生什麼事
我們來看一下
你看張圖你就知道很可惜
75%
對
這7.0是在這裡
第一根
後面呢
漲上來
天啊 漲到20塊
最高點漲了175%
那小的第一根賣了
很多人追不回來
我覺得就看一個紅K嗎
然後就看一個盤整
盤整紅K
這根最好用
在統計上面
就這麼簡單
對 盤整的大紅K
明天就來試喔
你可以每天把那個
大王可以找出來
對
看那個找盤整的喔
假如他是上下政當很大那就算了
對
盤整完第一根最好用
好一檔不夠
一檔不夠
對一檔不夠
一檔你不相信
對
我們做理化的話也是要多次實驗
才知道結果
沒錯
多找幾檔
來看一下艾普
艾普好
艾普呢第一根在這邊
好在這邊
這一根呢他有一點這個頭髮
有個頭髮
喔有點像影線
這個上一線
這叫鬍子叫頭髮
第一根在這邊
第一根那邊
第一根有點頭髮
有一點頭髮沒有關係
第二根就變凸了
第二根他沒有上影線的
沒有上影線跟有一點上影線都沒有關係
這兩根一出現之後
就代表怎麼樣
漲勢要開始了
我現在才意味到你的光頭大紅棒
是指他沒有頭髮
沒有頭髮
對
原來是這個意思
所以你說
第一根出現有點頭髮
第二根沒有
還是可以追
可是他這邊長
連張兩根還是可以追 為什麼
因為你看到下面的土你又知道
他還是可以追 各位看一下
他是在這裡 不是吧
53.1 後面最高到93塊
可是這個中西都不用搭配說
我站上什麼均線
或是我看成交量發生什麼事都不用嗎
通常他盤整很久的
他這根K棒就會讓他站上月線 季線
就等於是均線已經糾結了
糾結 然後躺在下面
對 他會一直站上
所以那些主力他們也知道
大家都在看這種東西
所以主力也會等月線季線
躺在下面的時候
他還踩拉這一根
因為萬一拉這一根
月線季線還在上面的時候
對他也是不利的
因為他會遇到上面的一些反壓
月線反壓季線反壓
他不好拉
所以我們看這個股票
只要他盤整夠久
第一根出來
很多都是表態
所以這樣橫盤
然後又站上軍線
然後又第一根
甚至到第二根
小哥都覺得還可以追
都可以追
好 這個75%
75%再看
小哥有沒有帶對象單來
對象單在YouTube上面都有
好 第三檔
第三檔 5906 台南KY
台南KY
這一根也是第一根
我們看一下
這個股價其實之前蠻無聊的
量也很少
這一根又讓這邊全部的人怎麼樣
一次都賺錢
那你賣在這個點就可惜了
為什麼可惜呢 我們來看一下
小哥 所以前面這邊都沒有到5%的光頭棒對不對
都沒有 就這一根
5%以上的光頭棒
光頭大紅棒
我們來看一下
這一根在這裡
後面呢 整個漲上來
85%的漲
所以這個呢 就
這我們叫做
橫盤爆亮大紅K
重紅K
重紅K是最好用的
對 因為我聽完這個
任何K棒這根最好用
也太簡單 我回去把大家的K線圖都叫出來
看誰還在這樣
然後明天誰突破我就掛誰
對 你可以這樣設計
有一種叫促價單
促價單是這樣子
這個你把股票都找好
然後只要明天漲9.5%
買進
漲9%不買 漲8%不買 漲7%不買
一趴不買 漲9.5%他就幫你追
天啊 就是漲停下一檔
對 漲停下一檔
小哥你教得好刺激喔
對啊 掛9.5%
9.5%
然後9.5%快漲停了 去追
在市場上我們看過很多追漲停的
富邦建國 土城永民
他們是越追越大
部位越來越大
因為他們大部分賺錢
因為他們很容易追到這種股票
所以有前提喔 不是高檔追
不是高檔追 是低檔
對 是低檔爆亮一根大壁
盤整很久的
好 OK 那接下來更刺激了
這個還是光頭大紅棒
對 這個你還有
你盤中還有機會進場
對 接下來跟各位講
這一個
是你盤中沒有機會進場
盤中沒有機會進場
我盤中沒有機會進場
我盤中他漲停我就去掛
不行嗎
這個絕對不行
絕對不行
這個你盤中看到你也不能掛
為什麼 因為這個叫做收購跳空以至限
如果他今天是收購才跳空的話
那一堆人知道他可能目標價很高
那他所長的題目為什麼我不能掛
為什麼 我們來看一下
我們來看一下這個圍滿張數
這邊圍滿張數是150萬張
你繳九點起床起得完
通常我們都講你做交易
要早睡早起 才看到新聞
九點 幾位都起床
你不要來做交眼 你去做別的工作
什麼
你現在都起床看到
已經開漲停板了
這時候你可能在190萬
這當天是190萬
我有看到
維買量
維買量 他是盤頭慢慢變少
對
你想看到190萬
你9點都在去掛的話
你是位在190萬人之後
對
對 你是拿到號碼牌
190多萬號
對
萬一你買到了 那慘了
為什麼
他今天報了歷史的天亮
代表前面100多萬張都買到了
那等於有人賣那麼多股票
代表有人刀那麼多
哇
不過這個股票也沒那麼大
有人刀那麼多的話
那嚴重了
這個舉是假的
喔
這個收購的舉是假的
所以小哥的意思是盤中不要掛
盤中不能掛
但是我記得你有偷偷跟我說
其實這檔你有掛到
那你怎麼掛
對
我怎麼掛呢
我們來看VCR
鬼脫買氣很苦
不是小根你這個是用什麼
開外掛去掛就對了
等等等等等等
我相信我們小時候在那個
小時候我們在雜貨店裡面
還有那種水果版的機子
對
那水果版機子
每次都有這個按鍵按著嘛
對
然後拿一根牙籤插著
所以那個那天怎麼掛
你拿一根牙籤插在鍵盤上
也是那種掛法
你就一直按著
一然他就委同買進城中
人工城市交易
對 用手按
對
那像琴藝的話速度很快
他可以一秒可以下20筆
對
所以你是在盤中這樣掛嗎
不是在盤前掛
早起
盤中絕對不能掛
好 剛剛小哥有跟我一直強調
盤中掛到就完了
盤前掛
因為盤中累積了190萬張
對 沒錯
而且你假如要確定一點的話
你什麼時候掛
你在8.55分的時候
就可以很確定了
因為8.55分你可以看到
他我也買張數贏到100多萬張
那時候掛來得及
因為在9點前
9點前你掛的都是亂數
拿號碼牌
所以你8.5點掛8.55都可以
都是亂數的
就拚人品
那我一次下一千張
可以啊 你下一千張有兩種下法
一次499 499
另外一次呢 下1000比1張
都可以
為什麼
有這兩種玩法
我最討厭那種一次下499的
對 為什麼
你像剛剛
例如說你排隊買紅豆瓶
排很久
不容易排到你前面哪一個
就你前面那個人跟那個老闆說
我要499顆紅豆瓶
整盧包走
你在後面就氣得要死
我明明快排到我了
你要喝499顆
上次有一檔就這樣
這是土城永林他掛499的
他沒比掛499
結果那次被他中了那一筆
所以成交499
後面每一張成交的都是他
都是他
所以後面我們都排不到
小哥我不會掛499啦
我也不會掛一千張
因為如果成交我沒有錢付
小你買到
這個我買張數還有100多萬張
你沒有錢付你來找我
真的
小哥幫我說
你明天一定會賺錢的啊
分我一半就好
沒問題沒問題
那你買到已經沒有人排隊了
不要找我
一定賠錢
小哥有告訴我們
可是我這邊還是有個疑問
因為剛剛講一致線
就是從頭到尾他都鎖掌庭
他只有一個架
可是我怎麼知道他不會打開啊什麼的
所以這種盤中
盤中我們都會設那個警示
例如說像這一檔
你可以設說盤中單量超過100張
通知你
現在下單軟體都有這種
所以你不用電他看啊
你只要示好警示
單量100張
看一下還沒有100多萬張
只要剩下2萬張你趕快撤單
因為代表他快要打開了
快要打開了
所以潘中要看一下
很多新聞都會讓一檔股票漲停
那怎樣的漲停
你會覺得你要在開盤前
就要去搶這個漲停
我們這樣子看
重期他的收購價是32塊
所以重點是他是收購對不對
對 收購的這種比較穩
銀收暴衝的貨利暴衝
貨利暴衝不行
都不行
東北塞
只有這個可以
老闆要收庫長股
要現真
小三買股票不行
全清買股票
全清買股票不行
全部都不行
全部的利多都不行
這種利多都不行
因為那種利多漲停板不一定鎖住
全部的利多只有一種利多你接收
只有收購的可以
你只接收購
你很明確
或者是他那個利多
導致那個圍買爆量
那種鬧勉強可以啦
因為這種收購的你知道價格在哪邊
像縱期他的收購價32塊
你22塊買穩的啦
因為他離32塊還很遠
所以收購是小哥唯一會願意去
但是小哥這邊有列出來
沒有列出來
我們來看一下
收購最怕什麼
明太收購的縱期收價32塊
那這個新聞看到32塊
那你22塊買就穩了
對 殺10塊也
那我們收購最怕怎麼樣
第一個買不到
當然啊 剛剛小哥講
你掛老闆店買不到
就很怕
第二個全部買到
這比第一個還恐怖
沒買到就算了
全部買到太恐怖了
像我們這個收購
我們通常一個戶頭
花上億資金去掛
你看 花上億才買到10張
對
因為他的那個中千率1千分之一而已
小哥你花上億去掛中期
還滿有實戰
花上億不代表你戶口的上億
你只要有大概3千萬
你就可以弄到一個上億的耳露
好
他在三倍啦
但是全買到其實剛剛小哥有告訴我
全買到
代表你的賣單太多了
對
你買了一億的中期完蛋了
這個局是假的
對
有發生過這種事嗎
有
有發生過這種事
就是要收購
事情讓很多人賠人產
叫樂生
樂生那時候收購128塊
115.5
一堆人去掛掌停板
就要掌停板開開觀觀
去掛的人都買到
都買到就不是好事情
所以樂生後面嚇死了
所以照理來說收購這麼強而有利的訊息
而且離他的收購價還有一大段
他卻開開觀觀
代表有人在盜貨
趁力多在盜貨
原來如此
所以收購一定不能爆亮
收購一定不能爆亮
對 爆亮就很怪了
那給各位看一下
我買在這一個
收購跳空一致線
所以你是第一天就買到了
我第一天就買到了
第二天 第三天我都買到
因為那個價格還遠
所以都買到
我都買到了
我們來看
這個第一根出現之後
後面兩根也都是一致線
那這根還能買嗎
我不像小哥這麼厲害
我今天才聽到
我這根還能買嗎
第二根還可以
因為離32塊含有
還有距離
對
第三根呢
其實買的就有點擔心了
因為離32塊就沒有含有
對
第三根之後開盤沒有漲停滿
這個時候我就賣掉了
我在沒有漲停的那天一定出掉
沒有漲停那天你就出掉
一定出掉
比如說你追這種一字線
追到他沒有漲停就賣掉
對
所以我在這邊買
然後兩根
這算算大概獲利率到20幾%
收購的時候小哥只賺
漲停板 漲停板 漲停板
沒漲停板就賣掉
不要再去等
後面有沒有什麼
台高收購價這些的問題了
沒錯
短線賺了就跑
三天賺二幾%
夠了啦
存股要存好幾年
有人中槍 古魚中槍
好
不過古魚那裡他可以存很多
像這個都要拚人品的
拚人品的 小哥人品好
買那麼多
總共要買到五六十張
對
第一天買四五張算比較多
好
所以這也是最近很有名的文業
文業也是被收購
大連大要併他
那文業這還是第一收購
第一收購我們還要特別小心
為什麼
因為你要看他的唯買量有沒有變少
第一收購是不是他會
例如他會到貨
故意到貨
萬一到貨怎麼辦
萬一到你全買到完蛋了
所以這是第一收購
這是第一收購
還好他還是一字線
小哥就進去了
我有進去
那我什麼時候賣呢
我在這時候賣
第一跟買嘛
一跟買嘛 第二跟一開高
這4 3.6是漲停版
對
漲停版我看他鎖不住我就賣掉了
喔 完全符合你的原則
鎖得住就爆 鎖不住就賣
沒錯
那你就看他的圍買章數就知道了
對
他圍買章數那時候我記得五六萬章
然後每一筆單都五六百章
你一除五六萬出於五六百
一百筆就敲開了
那其實不用到一百筆他就敲開了
收購新聞漲停鎖死
然後沒有鎖死 打開了就賣
對 沒錯
因為這一招讓你賺得蠻穩的
而且很快獲利出場
所以小哥已經教兩個進場的方法了
最後第三種可以棒 掉手線
又叫掉人線
高檔掉手線
第一個他的特斯老師他的實體很小
這根棒子很小
他不一定是紅K 也不一定是黑K
紅黑K都可以
那你如果高檔頭部你看到這個線型
要特別小心
對 因為高檔頭部呢
看到這種現行
這個下陰煙又很長
對 這偷藏啊
這個下陰煙很長
這段呢
在高檔突然擊殺
會導致怎麼樣
會導致肢減 眷減
可是如果他是洪K剛剛
照那個小哥教我的
代表他要買盤上來啊
對不對
他殺得生
但有人又把他買上來了
那代表呢
有人下車
另外一個人上車
對 這樣不好嗎
換手換手
高檔這樣子換手
他叫籌碼爛的話
換的人呢
很容易是閃護
哦 換到閃護手上了
對 閃護去追高了
原來如此
那這種呢 後面會怎麼樣
後面呢容易崩盤
容易崩盤
那假如是長期主力大賣的話
高點一斤
可是如果
這是高檔嘛
如果在低檔出現這個掉手線
低檔掉手線的話
他很容易變成一根釘子
那根釘子呢
會讓這個整個局勢扭轉
所以你看到掉手線
不管在高檔跟低檔
常常都是一個變盤的徵兆
變盤 那這邊的話
因為最近台股也在高檔
所以只要看到這個線
是不是就要小心一點
大盤K線是沒有長這樣
那到一個時候長這樣要很小心
這邊有些個股已經出現了
沒錯
我們來看這個掉手線的江坡圖
江坡圖 來看這裡
這檔是凱衛
好 凱衛
2016年11月21號
開盤漲停內
對 開盤逼近漲停
因為他這天我都記得
開盤漲停是50.3 他開50.2
結果一開盤之後一路往下殺
那這一路往下殺的過程中
會有一些人這個高檔婚禮了解
然後也會有一些空單呢
在往下殺的時候回補
寒淚回補
因為他已經被割受不了了
喔 好不容易有殺
讓他回補一下
所以在這邊會有空單的解套
對 空單解套 資簡卷簡
龍之也少了 龍之也少了
那他的K棒人就長這樣
K棒人長這樣
那會造成什麼後果呢
那帳股票呢 很有名啊
叫凱惠 每次人家問說
凱惠做個衛浴的
不是啦 還是凱惠資訊啊
不是凱撒衛浴
那這檔股票呢
在往上漲的過程中啊
就會來看一下
很特別的主力在賣超
主力在賣超怎麼可能
散戶在買
這就散戶
聰明散戶贏了耶
怎麼那麼厲害
我們說前半段的散戶
在這天賣的話
他是贏的
但我們從集保護書來看
大部分散戶都沒跑
所以散戶報上又報下
所以發生了什麼事
因為散戶呢
就可能參加了
某個理財社團
理財社團就叫他們
一張不要賣
不要賣啊 那很多人就沒有賣
那就很可惜啊 報上又報價
到底什麼樣一個神秘的社團
該不會是小哥的社團
我們社團是不會幹總事
因為這個掉手線
一直講掉手線出現在這邊
就在這裡
就是一個轉車
那到後面呢 你可以看到
這個一出現之後啊
這個高點一出現之後
你再數20天
再數20天
在數20天月線就會下彎
假如他沒有創新高的話
月線下彎
這檔股票一堆閃露在上面
到後面就是龍之多莎多
斷頭對不對
所以出現這個人踩人
掉手線的時候
不管怎麼樣
如果是這種已經漲上去一波的
就是先溜為妙
你要很小心
那時候我看到掉手線
我知道這檔股票差不多了
差不多了
氣勢已盡
氣勢已經差不多了
今天很謝謝小哥
好不好 三種K棒
幫我們省了很多時間
而且小哥還花了時間
幫我們做了一首叫做
K棒之王的歌
K棒之王
小哥第一次上節目
就要犧牲這麼大嗎
就要來幫我們高哥一曲嗎
因為你知道你有一個競爭對手
叫做阿哥嗎
阿哥有在節目上說
阿哥他歌舞很好
我歌舞比較差
他想要串你的胃
他說他是全正阿哥
不行 我們是籌碼小哥
好不好
所以我們今天要來唱一首K棒之歌
好的
聽說小哥要站起來唱聲音比較粗的來
對不對
我來伴奏
我以為看本意比參考買股
每一次買了都會噴出
我以為雖然賠錢一成往事
千言萬語說出來可以互相安撫
期待你翻盤
真實的阻力難相處
貪貧的讓我
登不到陰又漲幅
誰曾經被痛
看銀行糊塗才懂得
少了兩位數
更明星可哭
我一心相信
有些過我永遠不必等
所以我明白在燈火爛散處
為什麼會哭
你不會相信
研究錯嗎 有多幸福
只想你明白
我還看K-BANG
愛到腰突
聽完小哥的歌聲
我覺得小哥
你真的是一個堅持不懈的人
因為我本來以為小哥唱三句
就會停下來
結果小哥竟然把他堅持唱到完
我覺得太感動了
我還以為你會說
被股票耽誤的歌手
應該沒玩過
對 因為我是誠實的人
我只能說小哥是個有毅力的人
好不好 今天的歌有籌必報
小哥獻出了我們的兩個第一次
什麼呢
第一次講K-Bong
然後第一次唱了一首歌
在錄節目的時候
所以希望大家喜歡
我們今天的歌有籌必報
那大家想要聽小哥
想要什麼樣的主題呢
通通留言給我們
那小哥剛剛也很大方的說
因為小哥他真的
夾到非常多漂亮的大娃娃
如果大家喜歡的話
我們會在下一集開始
做有獎征達
只要答對小哥說的題目的話
這些漂亮的大娃娃Dream
就會送給你
我們今天的歌有熟悉吧
就到這邊了
我們之後再見了
Bye
字幕by索兰娅